it was on snl and so all the black snl
cast members are at this canned food
drive at the wayne manor right
and so they're kind of in line picking
up their food and bruce wayne's there to
greet them and they're kind of like
thank you thank you bruce wayne right
but you know batman right he's like yes
i do
it's like can you tell them to stop
beating up black people
you gotta see this kid in five four
three two
we're just going to go straight into it
so
did you
see the article
i literally just saw it today and it
[ __ ]
wrecked my ass about the odds of mine
long beach
no
bro i haven't heard about this lady in
long beach i think she's a liquor store
owner
korean lady
around the same age as our moms maybe or
maybe
more or less you're a mom yeah but my
mom's 60s okay yeah so the same age is
around your mom
runs the store guy comes in stabs her in
the [ __ ] neck like 10 times what
yeah some dude in long beach goes in
there and stabs her neck and she's
paralyzed from the neck down now she's
alive she's alive barely and i think
this was her last year before she was
about to retire
my [ __ ] worst nightmare dude yeah
that is
literally my worst [ __ ] nightmare
yeah
yeah that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] makes my
stomach girl it's like one of my because
my parents have been working i mean my
parents are kind of like a neighborhood
staple so it's a little yeah no my mom
is as well because yeah yeah you did my
mom you're [ __ ] dead yeah
not just like
by me like the neighborhood's gonna
[ __ ] fight yeah you know yeah
my mom has been the same way for the
community where she's at too yeah people
actually call her like
like a real staple of the community
because literally look this
korean-american immigrant has been there
for [ __ ] 25 years
you know yeah like yeah like i mean a
lot to them we've we've had that store
for
30 plus years now yeah so i mean the
idea so my parents are going to retire
soon too right but could you imagine
coming to this country
working here your whole [ __ ] life and
by the way too when you're
i think a lot of people don't know if
you own like one liquor store or you own
one small business yeah you're not
really rich you're not you don't make a
lot of money welcome to middle class
yeah like lower middle lower middle
class not like good standing i'm talking
about lower middle class right
and
you know one of the stuff that obviously
there's a whole history behind this that
you have to dive into as to why there is
like this disparity between like for
example like predominantly black
communities and asian communities and
i've talked about this multiple times on
the podcast but um my parents told me
this story recently too where this uh
this person's not a regular customer
because regular clusters never do this
my parents you know they're super sweet
um 99 of the customers are great one
percent pieces of [ __ ] so this guy
happens to be in that one percent and so
he comes in you know opens up a jar of
like of um
grease and then he starts putting it in
his hair
right this happens a lot yeah you know
my dad's like you can't do that you have
to pay for the product if you do that
right and he goes but you can't give me
some grease he goes look at you guys
over here just [ __ ] opening stores in
our neighborhood you know and profiting
and my dad's like i've been here for 30
years
you know
it's like we didn't just open this door
he goes yeah he goes
and then he goes yeah i bet you live
like over here in like west sacramento
in a big home and my dad's like i live
in south sacramento i'm probably your
neighbor
and he goes uh my dad said he got
shocked and he looked at me goes well do
you live in this park
like our poorness you know yeah and my
dad said he was just laughing it's like
you owe me an apology you know like like
you're stealing from us yeah i i can't
stand their [ __ ] too when people try to
look like they look at us like we're
um stealing from the community
it's just like
it sucks though i mean it's because like
history-wise too it just goes into whole
like the whole banking system how you
know these marginalized black
communities weren't getting along that's
100 real too yeah that's really
and that's why we understand where we
are with privilege yeah you know asian
americans or just asians when they got
here [ __ ] they were given opportunities
yeah they were given loans they were
like told like to diligently work and
and and do all these things and they
give zero
of that kind of opportunity to black
americans like we know this i think like
the the hard part is too because you
know when i see these articles too
obviously it's like heartbreaking and
you know
for for us to because our parents are
business owners we can empathize with it
and it probably affects us a lot more
closer to home than a lot of other
people yeah
because it literally could be our
parents it could be yeah you know you
know god forbid
but you know when we see these articles
and sometimes when i read the comments i
get [ __ ] irritated because
i i feel like with the whole when we
talk about asian identity and i don't
really talk about it too much because
it's so complicated and i feel like
sometimes i feel like i'm beating like
an old drum but
i i
i don't think we ever get our own voice
and identity when it comes to our own
issues sometimes yeah it's always like
who are you speaking for are you
speaking for this side or that side yeah
and it's like you know we kind of have
our own problems too yeah i'm speaking
for us yeah for our size i'm talking
about art issues yeah and
that's just
one of the sad things like stop asian
hate is kind of getting swept on the rug
and then there was the other news of the
girl in new york the korean girl oh um i
forgot her name i think it was christina
lee or something or something yeah where
she was oh this is crazy so this girl if
you guys don't know already she was
followed into her apartment she had an
apartment out in chinatown obviously not
a great area out in new york i think it
was around 4 00 a.m
um
follows her into her apartment it has
one of those like slow closing doors but
either it didn't close all the way but
he was following her like a like a
flight or a step a flight backwards
um door-to-doo's enters the apartment
and he stabs her
numerous amounts of times people were
saying she was stabbed 40 times i
couldn't find an article that said that
so i'm not going to i'm not going to go
ahead but
she was screaming
like fighting for her life and her
neighbors could hear it but you know new
york you know a lot of there's a lot of
noise people yell and fight so you don't
really know what it is but apparently i
heard she was or i was reading that she
was still alive when the cops were
contacted
so she was still fighting for her life
while the cops were trying to break in
but they couldn't get in and then he
escaped but she was stabbed to death
brutally murdered and her like clothes
were tatted too so they think they were
he was like trying to sexually assault
her too yeah and you know we hear about
these stories and they kind of just get
swept under the rug
and the hard part about that is that
when we talk about these things
you know some of the responses that we
get is we got bigger fish to fry it's
like
all right you know like like we're not
americans yeah you know we don't matter
one of the hardest things too i think
that um
people are trying to
they're kind of struggling with is the
idea that i think when a lot of these
things happen to
asian americans the first thing they
people ask isn't like i can't believe
this happened is was that person
mentally ill yeah you know so there's
already a built-in excuse for the person
who's the murderer first
versus
feeling sympathy sympathy for the person
that got murdered yeah it's like because
they're trying to figure out why would
someone do this and i understand that's
reasonable right but i don't think
that's the first thing you should
[ __ ] ask when somebody gets murdered
yeah
you know like you feel sympathy for the
person that committed the crime over the
victim first even at this point to have
to even think that why why would someone
do this like i don't know have you been
reading the [ __ ] news
why would someone do this i don't know
man tell me
yeah it's like as if like we haven't
been screaming about it yeah yeah yeah
yeah
and like i understand too it does make
sense like it it
i think the reason why two people are
trying to figure that part out is also
because they're trying to say hey
let's not make this a race issue right
which i understand
but you have to understand how victims
feel when they're scared and they feel
like somebody that they love just got
taken away from them and the first thing
you say is like well that was a crazy
person not how is the family this is a
heinous crime yeah that's what's
addressed first it's kind of [ __ ]
backwards to me yeah
well
the way i've been like really seeing it
too it just feels like every single
group of americans whether it's white
black latino
or latinx i guess
an asian
all
all sorts everybody feels forgotten
yeah you know that's very true everyone
feels forgotten why people feel
forgotten too that's why they're you
forgot that this is my country
[Laughter]
don't you ever forget
i'm kidding but there are certain parts
of this country that doesn't they do
feel like we'll rise again
brother
no but yeah [ __ ] white people feel so
forgotten but then we're out here and
we're screaming and we're saying we're
being forgotten and black americans yeah
they're being forgotten like we know
this yeah uh um native americans yeah
don't let me even literally forget
bringing them up yeah the real white
people yeah
no i mean like [ __ ] everyone is feeling
less and less scratching for everybody
scratching for a voice and
you know like i even uh
a while back i did this uh podcast where
we kind of brought up the topic about
the first time um nora or aquafina got
flack for her roles in her films were
they saying that she's portraying this
black scent right
and
this is a very interesting topic um i
think the first time the way i
approached it i know i defended her
vehemently and i actually still defend
her now right yeah and but i i do want
to explain why a little bit better
because i think a lot of people
they understood where i was coming from
but not really all the way right
when we look at people now um and you
have to and you have to look it as
through the lens of what's current now
right so her and her age she is a
millennial yeah right
millennials and gen z's we actually have
a lot more similarities than
dissimilarities yeah um
a lot of millennials were raised by
things like mtv
a lot of this stuff that was kind of fed
to this generation your generation of
mine were stuff that we saw glamorized
on youtube the internet tv or whatever
right
my defense of her or not even so much
defense just the rationale for people to
kind of like something to chew on is
that she grew up in new york right and
she's growing up around the culture
because number one she was a rapper and
they're like oh she didn't grow up in
like the heart of new york she grew up
in this uppity area yeah but everybody
knows too if you're watching this right
now and you're telling me that you
didn't grow up in the vicinity of area
you didn't pick up mannerisms you're
[ __ ] lying to me yeah you're 100
because look at me i grew up in south
sacramento california right but you hear
the way that i speak it's not completely
south sac you'll hear flips of it here
and there the reason why is because yeah
that's the neighborhood i grew up in but
my household wasn't like that yeah so
i'm like a mismatch of everything yeah
the same with my
weird accent like
um you know born in l.a in k-town then i
live in [ __ ] flint michigan then i
live in washington
you know um then i live like
in the [ __ ] sticks of washington like
stick sticks where everyone has this
draw
yeah and i lived there for a number of
years not only that i'm we're also
speaking korean at home that changes the
way we speak english
um that's why my accent is just my
accent i sound the way i do because i've
just been all over the place yeah and a
lot of people now are like a digital
representation of that right that's why
you hear dude i was at disneyland and i
heard these three little white kids
they're just walking around and they
said some really like gangster [ __ ]
and i'm like where the [ __ ] did they
learn this phrase they're like hey he
was like hey he's like hey remember they
just get stitches
don't suck where'd you learn that [ __ ]
you know but once again they're watching
[ __ ] on tv and they're watching things
online you know tick tock
tick tock or whatever right so when
people look at somebody they say well
because you're here this is how you
should speak i don't really think that
applies anymore yeah everybody's picking
up everything else dude uh rich brian
oh yeah look at him look at him his
original name was rich chigga yeah
and all these things his original his
old videos are pretty provocative yeah
and this guy grew up in [ __ ]
singapore or whatever right yeah
indonesia indonesia i'm sorry i listened
to his english yeah he learned it on the
[ __ ] internet yeah he learned the
internet english yeah you know what i'm
saying and look what it sounds like yeah
black american yeah because youth
culture and internet culture like uh is
like follows
what black americans are following like
young youth black culture here's the
thing too like i also want people to
realize too you guys have to understand
the black people are the coolest people
on earth yeah hands down it doesn't i
don't give a [ __ ] what you say dude how
many [ __ ] white people [ __ ] sound
like black people on twitter
when they talk and when they want a
[ __ ] period it's like it's like it's
like hip-hop culture right and i i think
when we say like black americans i'm
talking about hip-hop culture because
black people are black culture created
hip-hop you have to give them credit
yeah so at the end of the day when i
look at this it's like this is how i i
didn't put it like this but this is what
a producer friend of mine said he goes
he said that he always felt a little
weird about how sometimes people would
try to
number one tell people that hood [ __ ] is
black [ __ ] he doesn't like that
association at all yeah he goes i want
to keep those two things very [ __ ]
separate yeah because i don't personally
like that and he also says that number
two he always felt weird about like
sometimes the music that he would create
and he would see like some like a white
kid do [ __ ] and it gets popular off it
but he goes at the same time i'm the one
who made those beats and i made it
popular yeah so we're but without those
people we're selling this product to
them yeah right
um that was just his perspective on it
right the issue that we have here that i
see a lot with the whole aquafina thing
um or not just her what how everybody
feels about the subject matter is that
within this group there's a controversy
right that you'll see and i'm just kind
of
seeing it online where there's half
people saying hey
when she was in crazy rich asia no i'm
sorry
oceans whatever 15 or whatever eight
eight whatever
she was beat she was the dealer and
doing the cards so like she's not
imitating black culture i think that's
offensive she's imitating a hustler in
new york and whether you're black puerto
rican mexican asian whatever white
whatever what not if you grew up in the
in the heart of the city this these are
what the hustlers sound like and that's
what she's imitating she's not having a
black scent per se you'll hear that at
the chess tables yeah in new york city
yeah yeah yeah that's what they say so
that's like half what people are
defending right and the other people are
saying well she's not even really from
new york so she is doing a black scent
before we continue this podcast let's
keep this podcast sponsored by
supporting our sponsors i p
my friends did you know that browsing
online using incognito mode doesn't
actually protect your privacy listen
i've talked about this multiple times
you need
i p
vanish if you're browsing without
protection my friends you are out of
your mind that's why i use
ipvanishvpn to make it easy to stay
truly private and secure on the internet
what are you looking up i know
everything i shouldn't know everything
and all that dirty little stuff that
you're doing listen none of my freaking
business you freak that's why you
specifically should get ipvenish it's
super easy to use ipvanish is offering
an incredible 70 off their yearly plan
for our listeners with a 30 30-day
money-back guarantee that's just like
getting nine months for free and you
cheap [ __ ] you know you love
that word free free free free so go to
ipvanish.com brain and use promotional
code brain and claim your 70 savings
that's ipvanish as in i p v a n i
s h dot com
brain with this topic i think for me it
makes sense why people are offended and
let me explain why before people say
like no it doesn't make sense at all
just to kind of get your gears going on
this
it makes sense to me why people are
offended but i don't think it's fair to
pin it on her yeah right it makes sense
to me because it's the idea of this so
when we look at like black america and
you know black americans right
when they speak with a quote-unquote
hood accent all right or whatever like
hip-hop culture is influenced big in
their life right yeah and you hear
somebody
a lot of the times when people see it
when you the darker your skin color is
they go this person is uneducated
this person is not smart
right but when you see somebody when
they see somebody who is fair-skinned
for example like nora she does this they
go wow that's unique or that's funny
that's funny that's super cool but how
[ __ ] unfair is it that when this
person who has this skin color when they
do it suddenly they're uneducated yeah
they're dumb they're hood
so i can
so for for people to say saying it
doesn't make sense at all i think that's
wrong take a second to think about that
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] annoying
so i understand why people are annoyed
and i think for me when i was out in
when i did my last college show i was
trying to explain it to some of these
kids and they understood it too i was
like if you don't understand that
because you aren't black american
or african-american yeah
i'll put it to you like this remember
when you were an asian kid and you went
to school and you brought your [ __ ]
noodles and rice and people are like
that's worms yeah that's gross ill it
stinks and then
fast forward 10 years you see a
fair-skinned white chef
throw soy sauce in this dish and they go
wow look at this fusion yeah this is
some juicy [ __ ] this is the oriental
flavor
and he gets praised of being the chef
that's creating innovative flavors for
all the [ __ ] we got made fun of exactly
and got bullied for straight bullied
and that's how i think i would feel
about it if i was a black american or
african american it's like you've taken
something from us that you made fun of
us you said that we were uneducated
stupid and when somebody else does it
that doesn't look like us and now it's
[ __ ] cool yeah that's where it
becomes [ __ ] annoying so i think that
emotion gets tied to her but i don't
think it's fair to do it to her number
one because of the generation that she
grew up in she's imitating a character
of a new york hustler not somebody of a
certain skin color and then on top of
that she's also acting she didn't write
the script
you know yeah so
you know that's my defense of it right
but this whole thing in america when it
comes to like race it's just such a
touchy subject here yeah you know i mean
yeah like it seems like it has to be
like so specific to the character and
you're pointing out the character that
nora was playing yes right but then have
you seen that video of that white kid
who grew up in hong kong
no
[ __ ] chinese accent how dare you
appropriate our culture
yeah but look man like make a movie
about this kid yeah right you gotta okay
then you gotta cast a white kid and this
white kid has to speak in this chinese
accent sometimes a character calls for
it guys yeah you have to say he's gonna
be one of the kids in stranger things
[Laughter]
dude i mean look that's that's what i'm
saying like
it's so complicated it's because people
want to be represented right but nora's
representing a type of person that is
very unique in new york that it [ __ ]
exists yeah it exists
they exist
yeah that's that's that's the part where
it gets really tricky for me you know
and
it's just america and race issues are
always odd like even the idea that
certain parts of this country refuse to
teach the
the black history part
of our history right in america which
even for me like the idea of calling
something black history hearing me out
doesn't make much sense because black
history is american history you should
teach it in all [ __ ] schools it's a
huge part of this [ __ ] country yeah
the fact that you have an option to even
take it out is so stupid yeah i mean
that crt [ __ ] is like a whole nother bag
of [ __ ] not [ __ ] but like just
chaos yeah the critical race theory
right yeah yeah rice theory i mean like
and
you know what what we're talking about
right now for the last however many
minutes is critical theory pretty much
you know it just annoys me the fact that
black history has to be something that
has to be implemented when really it's
just part of it it's history it's a part
of america's history
backbone the culture
everything that you see right like i
literally just said it everything that
black people have made and touched has
been turned into something cool yeah
they are the epitome of a culture that
knows how to take their [ __ ] lemons
and make lemonade out of it yeah you
look at something
even this if you like [ __ ]
smoked barbecue you love black people
yep you know
taking these scraps
these tough pieces of meat that they
were given and turning it into something
tender
yeah yeah it's it's crazy to think that
there's parts of this country that
doesn't they don't want to teach this
part of the part of history and yet at
the same time
they can reprimand you know countries
like china who wants to get rid of their
parts of history because they don't want
and they you know they have their nose
up at people at china when you're doing
the same thing here
doesn't make any sense yeah i mean you
can read it on the news man they're
trying to literally just take out so
much [ __ ] out of school books and like
there was a big thing last month about
there was huge bar book burnings all
across
like different parts of america because
i guess some states made it legal to
burn a book you know or they just like
got rid of all these like
controversial quote-unquote books at
public libraries dude just understand
like i'm not trying to get on my social
justice [ __ ] i think these are just
facts black history is american history
it is and from somebody who didn't you
know i'm not i'm korean american i was
born in korea when i look at it like
that it's like
that just is what it is there's no
how many times by the way dude this is
why it's also obnoxious to me it's like
how many [ __ ] times do i have to hear
about [ __ ] george washington's stupid
wooden teeth
why is that ever relevant you do you
realize too in elementary school they
bring that [ __ ] up like three times over
it tell us the part when when they told
the slaves to build the white house
no that didn't happen dude yeah to build
all the roads and build all the cities
dude there's there's places in new
orleans that if you go right now you
could still see i forgot what the title
for it is exactly but you could see the
fingerprints of the slaves who built the
brick houses there into the [ __ ]
bricks right yeah but you don't want to
teach it in history which does not make
sense to me it's not to reprimand you
know white americans or anything like
that but
it's a part of history that built this
country that people should [ __ ] know
yeah which it's like when you give black
people an opportunity
white people feel like it's being taken
away
right which i think is a good way to
segue into what being a forgotten white
american
feels like peacemakers baby right
peacemaker how apropos yes peacemakers
so you know ed has been trying to get me
to watch which i did but i was moving
and setting up this podcast finally had
a time to go sit down and watch it i
watched one episode i thought it was
amazing sat down watched a second [ __ ]
watched it all the way through in one
day yeah because it was that [ __ ]
good yeah peacemakers is so [ __ ] good
number one already love james gunn right
and we've talked about um
guardians guardians of the galaxy being
one of the best origin stories for any
type of marvel film yeah ever and once
again done by james gunn
um james gunn to me in terms of his
directing
by the way too the jokes
and this is
[Laughter]
let's just go into the first episode
just that first scene between the
janitor the indian janitor
and that [ __ ] peacemaker made me die
laughing yeah and usually when i see
these like really quick just banter
scenes it seems a little corny and kind
of play let's kill some time it's like i
i [ __ ] live for these moments
maker yeah because number one it already
showed even if you didn't watch the the
the what do you call it what movie was
it suicide squad the suicide squad movie
before which would help if you watch the
series
but you kind of already get to see his
character in that first scene alone
right even if you didn't watch the movie
and i the one line that cracked me up
was when he was like you've been killing
hella black people yeah
right yeah
what are you talking about i just killed
criminals he goes well it's kind of
weird that the statistic shows that you
killed more black people than you white
people he's like [ __ ] you then i'll kill
more white people then does that make
you happy yeah
yeah dude i mean that's what's so genius
is is how
james gunn off the bat is
with even the but that
it took a serious statistic it made it
to a joke which is kind of crazy genius
right but implemented it into
peacemaker's character of what he thinks
he is as a superhero right because only
before it was on snl
when chance the rapper was hosting they
did a bruce wayne skit right and so all
the black snl cast members are at this
fundraiser at this canned food drive at
the wayne manor right
and so they're kind of in line picking
up their food and bruce wayne's there to
greet them and they're kind of like
thank you thank you bruce wayne right
and then they're like but you know
batman right he's like yes i do
he's like can you tell him to stop
beating up black people
you got to see this kid you gotta see
this skit cause
it's so [ __ ] good it's hilarious too
it kind of follows it right but then
it's so hilarious that you know james
gunn like made it into
this character like for you to really
see and look and not really make a joke
out of it but like build this guy's
character like where he comes from if a
guy was like that and had these
arguments for why he did like you know
how i've heard this argument a million
times about like
you know that black on black crime
statistics [ __ ] like that right and
and they were touching on that the fact
that like he made the argument like i
just go where crime goes and then you
guys are like yeah it's just black
people why don't you
like keep an eye out for white people
just as much as you do for black people
yeah you're right so he makes her
promise yeah i'll kill more white people
thing yeah it's like deal yeah look how
serious this [ __ ] the matter of what
they're talking about is but how genius
is it to make you [ __ ] laugh at it
because that's who this guy is and it
also goes to show how dope of a [ __ ]
actor john cena is yes oh my gosh okay
yeah let's talk about john cena for a
second amazing amazing he's so good
number one
as a serious actor the way he emotes and
how he [ __ ] executes cop like comedic
lines yes he's funny too that's so
[ __ ] hard to do yeah
he is amazing dude yeah might like him a
little more than the rock then the rock
i feel like i think she's better yeah
the rock as an actor
wishes he was john cena but the rock as
an entrepreneur yeah he's on his own
yeah but when i look at their acting and
you know we've seen the rock in a lot of
different films you know from
you know i'm not pitting these two
against each other i'm just telling them
you guys about because they had similar
upbringing where they came from wwe and
into hollywood and he was the one who
took the crown from the rock after the
rock left that void of like super
stardom i think john cena was the next
one up
but john cena's acting is on another
level yes he's a much better actor it's
so [ __ ] good like
peacemaker 2 is such a
complicated character
a lot more complicated than i kind of
expected watching watching the series
yeah because
he sees
so if you guys haven't watched obviously
um spoiler alert but well if you guys
yeah it's all spoilers so every time we
talk about something it's all spoilers
because
number one he's such a detraction from
what he thinks he's supposed to be a
detraction from who his father is yeah
his father you know you know how you
have like a
uh
kkk grand wizard yeah he's he's ten
steps above that yeah yeah he's high he
is the grand master
so he is the red dragon yeah right which
is what's the backstory behind the red
dragon and all this tech that he has um
i well the comic book itself where it is
like part of a storyline work he is a
white supremacist villain like dc told
stories like that because dc's like
dc's characters like they're all in
these crazy looking suits all the time
all of them are like these really
colorful suits
marvel went towards a route where it was
still our universe physics and science
base right yeah um
so
like everyone has a propulsion system
one way or another if they fly
right
but in dc it's just
beyond fixes all these these people are
god's kind of things right and for dc
though in order to make them have more
relative stories was with that was that
they they dug deep into who they were
especially in the 80s yeah you know it's
when we saw a really dark batman too
that's where the dark knight comes from
the dark knight returns uh frank miller
wrote those series
and so dc's and the watchmen came out 85
or i mean sometime in the 80s too my
lovely brain farts this podcast is
brought to you by raycon you know i've
talked about raycon i've talked about
wireless earbuds that are affordable
that sound dope they're super light and
compact and that's my raycon earbuds i
do not play raycon earbuds is my [ __ ]
wireless earbuds are the best way to
bring audio with you because no matter
how much you shake things up literally
no matter how much you shake you know
they won't fall out your ears i'm
talking about i go on my bike about 100
miles per hour i'm not talking about a
motorcycle i'm talking about a bicycle
my friends when you're really large and
you go down a hill let me tell you
something gravity is a [ __ ] and guess
what my raycon earbuds don't fly out my
fat chubby ears raycon offers eight
hours of play time on the 32 hour
battery life and they're priced just
right you get quality audio at half the
price of other premium audio brands
right now
my genius brain listeners you can get 15
off their raycon order at buy recon dot
com slash brain that's by recon dot com
slash brain to get 15
on ray cons that's by rey khan dot com
slash brain
yeah this character read dragon over the
years evolved a lot like he is a white
supremacist like he his alter ego is
like this um personality i forget if
he's a politician or tv personality or
some [ __ ] but he spews these [ __ ]
racist ideologies like these
supremacists but they're like underlying
ideologies to the public
right and so clearly he's like this this
[ __ ] ain't any good so that's a lot of
where his character's background does
come from
but the technology and all of that stuff
i think they made it just for the show
oh okay i was so confused was like why
does he have all this [ __ ] i don't
understand this you know i i think it's
it's one of those i guess superhero
tropes like 07 has q or whatever too but
like you know bruce wayne having lucious
fox or whatever i think they just served
it into the story that his father is
responsible for all of
peacemakers suits his uh equipment his
training
right i mean and that that was explained
in
like just a few lines in suicide squad
yeah he was in prison right amanda
waller was like his father trained him
to [ __ ] kill murder and do all this
[ __ ]
but then what the show is also revealing
though
is that
especially in that opening uh dialogue
between the janitor and he was that um
everyone believes that he's a racist
everyone thinks he's a super villain
everyone
thinks yeah he's just like a [ __ ]
murderous
bad guy but
he's oblivious he's oblivious he really
in his head believes that he's a
superhero that he's always doing the
right thing in the name of peace
right i think it's how [ __ ] odd this
villain his name is peacemaker
his father has that cloud over his head
too because everybody knows who his
father is
it's like of course the apple doesn't
fall from fall far from the tree right
and
that speaks into a lot of
white americans these days like our age
the 30s 20s even the four the gen x
white guys
you know
i mean
they were tired of just being called
racists
just because their fathers they know
their fathers are right we know white
boomers like yeah a lot man you know
it's very hard to find you know like
it's they're just
you know how they are there was talk to
them yeah that's what how they were they
like lived through the civil rights
movement and all that [ __ ] and a lot of
them were against it yeah you know and
they're alive today
that's what we know about boomers but a
lot of gen x especially
like they weren't like that they were
just raised by them and that's who
peacemaker is and and generally online
you see some
uh 30 40 50 year old white guy you
assume he's a racist yeah just because
yeah i mean these are things i had to go
through too through my therapy because
of all the [ __ ] i've told a million
times
about the [ __ ] i went through at the
store like i started getting this
generalization of white people so i went
to therapy because i was recognizing
that i was being a [ __ ] racist yeah
yeah yeah you know um so
i i was just so amazed how james gunn
touched this topic
like because
i was saying earlier even white
americans feel forgotten
right and he dove into that story of a
forgotten white american
he was told he was going to be great he
was white americans too you know they're
told that they're old the world you know
and they're given everything but look at
him
living in a [ __ ] trailer his best
friend is a [ __ ] eagle his other best
friend is autistic yeah you know like i
mean that that's a bad thing i'm just
saying like um they're not
he specifically says that
he he's around people that don't
communicate normally well at all because
he eventually hangs out with a [ __ ]
butterfly yeah because regular like
neurotypical people and all that stuff
like just general society hates him
you know so he does he that that's why
they're not his best friends these
people who
are just out of like
humanity type of people are his closest
people because he doesn't have to talk
about all the reasons why they hate him
you know it's interesting because
there's a part of the film where you are
not film it seems like a film but the
series where
you get to see the origin of
how toxic his relationship is with his
father right yeah and like the onset of
his trauma is actually the death of his
brother yeah where his brother
he and his brother were forced to fight
each other yeah right for for his dad's
like little ufc backyard club exactly
and then he decks his brother and his
brother has a seizure
and he chokes and he dies right but his
father looks at peacemaker and says that
you [ __ ] eat it you killed your
brother
yeah like this is your fault
right even though clearly it's not his
fault yeah it's his piece of [ __ ] dad's
fault yeah right
and
his dad also too has his own delusions
his dad is just as delusional as he is
yeah he doesn't see that he blames he he
literally blames his son for the death
of his other son even though it's his
fault you used your kids as a [ __ ]
cup you know cough fighting rings yeah
what in those boys like they weren't
even teenagers at that point you know
yeah he's very clearly a [ __ ]
terrible bad guy so yeah um played by
robert patrick right uh t-1000 yeah yeah
which is crazy
yeah like wow you look way different
yeah i mean this this role really
revives his career for sure she he was
so [ __ ] good at playing a piece of
[ __ ]
[ __ ] oh my god so the first episode
uh
peacemaker gets out of the hospital and
um you know because in the suicide squad
he was in prison after whatever
operation they did he's supposed to go
back to prison but he just goes home
yeah right and so he goes to see his dad
and
and we get to know his dad and
he's a [ __ ] homophobe
he's a racist
he's a misogynist he is all everything
just piece of [ __ ] boomer
like yeah and so that's who peacemaker
was raised by
right and then um
like he calls him the f word
a lot yeah
um he disparages the [ __ ] asian
detective
they're banter
the racist asian jokes they call her
chopsticks
that she was making me laugh so hard
because of it was like the oldest racist
asian jokes you could ever think of dude
yeah they were like they were too easy
right like i mean and it's obviously so
because he's such an old guy i think it
just served more than he's just this old
piece of [ __ ]
also too one of the things that i really
[ __ ] loved was the
the asian actress i wish i remembered
her name right now apologies i don't
remember your name but she was so
[ __ ] good yeah and that she also had
her detective partner who he essentially
was playing the same person that he was
in white chicks yeah
he was also the baby dick guy in scary
movie yeah
that fool was cracking me up because i
was like dude this whole james gunn saw
him in white chicks and he was like
you're just gonna play the same
detective and white chicks here i need
you yeah he just got to play the same
character fool's cracking me the [ __ ] up
um but yeah uh so
we know his father's a piece of [ __ ] and
so it's it's expressed by his neighbor
the next door neighbor he gives him [ __ ]
and like thinks he's that he's a super
villain too just like his dad his dad is
a retired supervillain yeah oh gosh
when they um
somebody who i really really [ __ ]
liked in the show too was who turned out
to be his best friend i forgot her name
right now that she was uh
har
harcourt
uh no the the old dubai arbaio
autobiography there you go she was so
[ __ ] she was good oh my gosh she was
so good in this show yeah and he she it
was interesting because her placement in
in the whole the new suicide squad
anyways was she was a spy yeah yeah for
her mom yeah double agent yeah she was a
double agent the whole [ __ ] time but
the [ __ ] even that too is hilarious too
because she's supposed to be the secret
of double agent spy and i think she
worked at what a bed bath and beyond
before
she's just like
she's so human yeah you know but then
this is just what she does because
there's that running theme of who her
mom is like yeah the first suicide squad
movie was a piece of [ __ ] but then you
really get to know amanda wallace viola
davis in the suicide squad was really
good and then the the next suicide squad
that's so hard their suicide squad and
then the suicide squad which is the
second one
she was also like showing her [ __ ]
ruthlessness and then then when we see
peacemaker we're saying oh this is the
offspring of amanda waller and so as
viewers we know
who amanda waller is and how [ __ ]
evil she is but then we're getting to
see the other side of the coin of
peacemaker and his shitty dad with
arbayo and her shitty mom
you know and it's like two polarizing
different kind of people type of people
who become [ __ ] best friends yeah oh
my god the other sides of two worlds
yeah right and who can write that better
than james gunn man
and by the way this is a guy too who was
purported as a [ __ ] racist yes
right and yes and his best friend at the
end of the day throughout this whole
series becomes this young black woman
yeah that's his best friend which is
kind of like his redemption yes
exactly exactly it's so good so good
i mean the the way it we we see his
character build and grow and such right
like
um i i said in the last podcast when we
were gonna catch up on this uh harcourt
the the bomb lady lon lady app is that
her name i can't remember i watched it
so fast
um
she represents the rest of all of us as
well as is the way we see
you know peacemaker like uh
i mean he's definitely a little slow and
a little gross too though yeah
especially like in the bar scene where
he's just trying to [ __ ] her yeah
she's like dude just give me a [ __ ]
break i just want to be alone yeah but
then i mean like but that that's the
thing he's just so like yeah this is
what i want yeah as a matter of fact
right but then
we also see that there is uh his
intentionality in so many things because
that's his intention right
his intention is to [ __ ] her so he's
trying to play his game yeah but then
when they're at the restaurant earlier
and he orders something and he calls the
waitress sweet cheeks yeah right he's
like what
what do you mean i'm talking about her
cheeks on her face that's so gross i'm
not talking about her but
so it's like there's this weird
innocence to him
right because of his [ __ ] ignorance
yeah you know it's like his ignorance
doesn't lead to just his racism you know
he laughed so hard yeah what he was
talking about her face
like a stupid [ __ ] lie yeah
yeah but that's that's what's so great
about this show and james gunn like
these little small little
quibbles and and and the [ __ ] banter
that they have is just so [ __ ] great
but like each one of them serve a
purpose for who they are and why they
think this way but you also notice that
the waitress she interpreted the way
that he said it
she had no problem
with it the whole table was like you
know that's so gross
you're gross
oh my god we're only talking about the
first episode so far right now you know
for real though i mean
okay yeah there's so much to talk about
this um
what what happened in the second episode
man i can't just it all comes together
like a film at this point yeah because
there's eight episodes it's and they're
40 minutes each yeah so we're looking at
five six hours hours hours yeah hours of
content another good part of the film
was it kind of always goes back um and
if you guys have been listening to these
reviews one of the biggest things that
makes me enjoy a film is character
consistency yes right there isn't a re
there is there isn't a random reason to
why things just happen there's you could
see these little glimpses of their
either their humanism or their
dehumanism like in their character to
make us feel uh a certain way about them
so you know we're talking right now
about peacemaker being a very
conflicting character
the assassination scene right you're
supposed to kill that little kid yeah
but but they are so okay so there's
these aliens they're like these
butterflies and they take over human
brains and control them right and they
get intel that this that the governor of
washington state so
let's let's leave like go on a tangent
for a little bit it's set
where my store is
in washington dude peacemaker could have
been my [ __ ] customer yeah you know
that's why i love this show you know
because through my therapy like it
helped me resolve like my resentment for
that area out there
and this show really opened up the
humanity you know what peacemaker is
though right peacemaker is the [ __ ]
employee that you had that got shot and
he came to work
he's peacemaker
yeah that's what he is yeah better help
better help it's all about that mental
health listen
i have used betterhelp for a very long
time you guys already know this and you
know there's a reason why there's still
a constant sponsor on this podcast is
that if you've heard this ad before and
you haven't tried it yet just give it a
go man better help online therapy offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to and by the way it's much more
affordable than in person therapy and
you could be matched with therapists in
under 48
hours i'm telling you
if you focus on your physical health you
should focus on your mental health too
it's just as important and matter of
fact maybe even more important than your
physical health because if you're not
healthy up here you're not going to be
healthy anywhere else this podcast is
sponsored by betterhelp and
geniusbrainlisteners get 10 off their
first month at
betterhelp.com genius that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p dot com slash genius
he's just ignorant to whatever else is
out there
you know it doesn't matter it's just
through his his thoughts his ideology
his beliefs and that's the world around
him yeah
and but when he's exposed to the rest of
the team who come from all over the
corners of america
you know they judge him super hard when
i was watching the film too and i saw
his interactions with his dad you see
peacemaker and his dad i was like that's
you and your dad bro
it's literally you and your dad yes yes
so we were gonna that's the last thing
that i mentioned in the last time we
talked about uh peacemaker
was that peacemaker is a better shangqi
right and yes we [ __ ] bring up
shanghai all the time and we [ __ ] on it
like whatever
um
we
i had a problem with the shanxi
father-son relationship because
you know i've mentioned in the past my
dad was a gangster in k-town uh he was
part of a
group gang called kk
um
he wasn't gen a general
good person yeah let's say right so i
know what it's like to live under that
kind of person but when i saw shang chi
i wish when wu was my dad
you know
that kind of love like for him to teach
like the the kind of lessons he taught
and whatever like he wasn't
a bad father because he was strict yeah
for no reason for no reason right
um but then what we talked about was the
problems that shang chi had was that it
it didn't show
the exposition it just told us
right and this was the scene where he's
crying in front of the lake or whatever
where he says that his father sent him
on a mission to kill
the the gang leader of whoever killed
his mom
and he did go and kill them but he told
him in the story
we needed to see that happen you know
like what created this changchi and this
hurt and this regret and all these
things yeah because especially then when
you kind of just tell it into words in
my mind i was thinking yeah no [ __ ]
[ __ ] killed your mom bro
right
right
and like it it didn't show us a badass
assassin it showed us a good guy in
hiding who didn't want to be an assassin
but like why
because that's something we didn't see
right because also too the reason why
that doesn't make sense
is the fact that
at this point
getting vengeance for somebody killing
your
mother over
these people who are essentially
villains
is that makes him the good guy
so
you guys have to understand like why i
just don't give a [ __ ] you know yeah
like it didn't make sense and that's
like the plot point to a lot of other
superhero stories i don't know yeah you
know
it's like i don't i don't understand how
how that was missed you know what i mean
it's just a little but you know when you
see when you're rapping back to
peacemaker you see what a piece of [ __ ]
that is yeah so and we see in a
flashback how he
was in a like a like a cockfight with
his brother because his dad organized
these [ __ ] fights
between that they're adolescers children
pretty much and he accidentally kills
his brother
because he hits him and his brother goes
and sees her and dies
and his father blames him for that as
well right and then
later on we see
how
his father starts raising
him where
he hands him a knife so in chiang chi
when we will hand sanctuary a knife like
a a like a
it's not like a
knife it's like a spirit or whatever
right
um and
that's why as soon as i saw the scene i
was like holy [ __ ] they're [ __ ] doing
it
though like when he ends in the knife we
see a guy tied up in a [ __ ] chair
begging for his life
and his father is calling him like all
these derogatory names like a [ __ ] like
to [ __ ] kill this guy and he as a
child stabs this guy to death
right
and then we see
peacemaker
praying
praying to god
like please like
like take this away from me all this
[ __ ] like i will
i'll do whatever i'll do anything for
peace
anything for peace and this is where he
more or less like
where he is mirrored with his best
friend vigilante
where they are stone cold killers
murderers he has an argument with his
neighbor about batman dude that [ __ ] was
so funny
like the banter like once again there's
like so much gold in every single one of
their rants like when he so he talks
about batman he calls him a [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah cause he doesn't have
the guts to kill the joker he doesn't
have to kill the guts to kill anybody he
just throws him back in jail and they
just [ __ ] get out and then they wreak
havoc again yeah he should just [ __ ]
kill them
right i think the funny thing is like
dude just having conversations
you're just [ __ ] with the bulldog
so it's your problem bro
i mean it's so hilarious to me that this
is an official dc
warner brothers project and they talk so
much [ __ ] about the justice league yeah
like that's another hilarious thing
about his character is that he knows he
he tells all these rumors about every
single
uh justice league member right and he's
like what i heard it on facebook oh yes
yeah what you mean some random guy in it
would just lie to me yeah
and it's like it's like aquaman
that's the ongoing joke right
so [ __ ] hilarious like and
it's
it's like they're deadpool i think
that because since this is their uh
rated r property they're just gonna go
there yeah but deadpool without the
[ __ ] over jokes and the concept
breaking of the assistant yeah god [ __ ]
man like deadpool one was like oh it's
cool yeah deadpool two it would
he went two times
i was like
one was borderline a little too much but
it was so funny
two how do you why would you double that
yeah it was crazy it was ridiculous it
killed all the scenes with that that he
had in this dream state with his fiancee
you know i heard um
i think was it tim miller he was the one
who did deadpool one i believe in the
first one so he was off a deadpool too
yes and i think he went head uh butted
heads with uh ryan reynolds of course
about the joke stuff he wanted to go
i think there was a little bit of an
argument between
um kind of where he wanted to put the
story in and it was less jokey
deadpool yeah um and i think ryan
reynolds didn't like that yeah and they
butted heads so tim miller who they're
going to choose timberland reynolds
audios yeah it was easy choice yeah i
mean like typically like that
i get it though like um to make a less
jokey deadpool like it wouldn't make
sense it wouldn't make sense either yeah
yeah that it's just kind of like having
a less dark gritty batman yeah you know
it's just like wait that's not batman
exactly
they introduced that one kid that the
one little asian kid judo yeah yeah
[Laughter]
well he's [ __ ] up everybody dude yeah
so i [ __ ] looked up this guy i'm
sorry i can't even remember his name
yeah um he's not as short as he is on
the show they'd use
it really looks like they use cgi to
shrink him oh really yeah he's not that
small in real life oh okay yeah he's
just eating cheetos yeah
he he's flaming hot cheetos
and he talks mad [ __ ]
that [ __ ] was so good every character
was so [ __ ] dope yeah it was so good
yeah oh we're talking about yeah so you
know i didn't understand
i was getting frustrated because he
couldn't
kill this family that they found out
were butterflies yes yes he could i was
getting frustrated at first but once
again there's a reason why especially
when it came to that kid he [ __ ]
killed his brother yeah yeah so that's
why he was having this crazy flashback
or whatever
and i think like at this point
they were even showing it early on was
him kind of realizing that yo maybe i am
a super villain
because he keeps killing people yeah you
know and just from that from these
conversations of him starting to realize
what he's doing and people's perception
of him and you see that when he goes
into the trailer which was a really cool
humanizing moment where he was just
crying right oh so leading up to the end
of the first episode he kills the the
first lady he [ __ ]
oh yeah the butterfly yeah the butt she
ended up being a butterfly and then he
uses the helmet his dad gave him
um
uh some sonic boom yeah and obliterates
by the way this this guy this whole show
was very gory as well um but it was
pretty badass the fight scenes too very
done very well um but uh
uh what wait what so i'm so sorry what
are we talking about right now we were
talking about his first i started with
his brother why he couldn't kill it kill
his brother
um
and with the reason why is because he
had
um
he couldn't kill the kid because of his
brother right right and then i talked
about the butterflies and then we
mentioned the
um
the [ __ ] what's it called
oh [ __ ] what are we talking about oh man
i was trying to lead up into what
happens when he goes in oh the trailer
he starts crying he's crying in the tree
he's crying on the trailer right so
after all that [ __ ] happens he has like
a really shitty escape
you know um
where uh he gets out of the situation
but everyone gives him [ __ ] for it and
then uh when he goes back to his trailer
he starts crying
but then what is he saying as he's
crying everybody hates me everybody
hates me you're such a [ __ ] dumbass
yeah and he starts disparaging himself
like it's true you're a [ __ ] idiot
you don't know anything
um
because outside of that exp exterior of
being a hard ass
like jock who [ __ ] makes fun of
everybody
you know um
he he pushes people away like
intentionally for some reason he can't
understand at that moment and he's just
pulling his eyes out and that's when we
meet vigilante coming in he's like what
are you doing what's going on right and
his character too vigilante great he's
highly on the spectrum he's so on the
spectrum
um
he can't even pronounce his emotions
yeah
his
his emotional thing like i mean it's
used for comedy too but it's done very
well because we have friends that are
kind of like him they're not too is that
kind of extreme but then like i think he
touched it
so well into this character who was just
like not on our thinking plane yeah dude
the scene that cracked me up so [ __ ]
hard was when peacemaker was supposed to
get tortured but they just keep
torturing vigilante
and then the alien butterfly it's like
we know that humans feel empathy towards
another so you can't stand to see your
friend get tortured
yeah he's like do it i don't care
so he
almost cuts off his toe
but you know it goes back to him in the
car and he was like you know thank you
for this [ __ ] experience like i
almost lost my toes like you're being
sarcastic
he's like you're you're mad at me no i'm
not yeah
but clearly he is
the banter is so amazing i mean the
little
like through lines like it's it's never
feels like it's wasting time
right a lot of
shows sometimes because oh my god we
have 10 episodes to fill
like put in like [ __ ] filler [ __ ]
like you know you know how dragon ball z
was growing up like between them waiting
for the manga to finish they had to
animate all this [ __ ] stories yeah
you know that's nice
right and even like it so you get a
contract for this many episodes and then
oh my god so you have to fill in all
those scripts and sometimes like you
have a montage to kill time for [ __ ]
or whatever but like
this show is so [ __ ] solid all the
way around where every scene and every
line like like serves a purpose towards
learning who their character is or
progressing the plot or even if it's for
the sake of comedy and it's totally uh
irrelevant holy it hits it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's funny hard man yeah and that's
why i was saying it's the best show on
tv so far yeah like this year yeah i i
binge watched it so fast and there are
certain things that i do binge watch and
i feel like there are a couple episodes
i just go through just to get over it so
i can get to the meat of the story yeah
it i it ended so well it started well
and the meat of it was really really
[ __ ] good and like
they even go into the more you'll see
what the butterflies are for it talks
about [ __ ] environmentalism yes yes
you know and then so once again they
they i mean i like where all these
superhero stories are going so far
because a lot of people thought there
was superhero fatigue and so there'll be
a lot less superhero like oh okay the
the it's it's gonna crash or whatever
like just like the way we saw westerns
they used to be huge nobody watches them
so um but
superheroes movies still find a way to
reinvent themselves yeah right and like
this extends like really well into
looking into new ways of how to look
into the mind of a superhero yeah yeah
really well and you know when they when
they so basically with these butterflies
they're an alien
form that came to this earth because um
you know there's a lot of abundance on
it and they were living very quietly at
first but their planet got destroyed
because of them kind of ignoring these
tail signs of like pollution and what
they're doing to their environment
through like technological advances or
whatever which is essentially what
humans are doing here yeah and so now
there's this moral choice it's like so
now they've decided to take over for
earth for the sake of mankind and take
over everybody on earth right so they
don't destroy earth which is their last
place to be because they've already
[ __ ] up their earth right which is
[ __ ] dope i was like yeah and it kind
of goes into this idea and you guys will
find out that one of the the the head
person in the suicide squad team that
put them all together he turns out
actually to be a butterfly yeah but he's
not looking to take over earth he is
against his own kind because he doesn't
believe
that saving earth from themselves by
taking them over by taking away their
free will is saving them at all yeah he
thinks that it's morally corrupt and
it's wrong right which is a really
complex topic right and it gets even
more complex with mern his name is mirn
right because he i think peacemaker
calls him out right on that [ __ ] it's
like wait but you took over somebody's
body or it might have been autobio
you know you took over someone's body
now who are you to say like why you want
to stop all this [ __ ] like you just you
know but then he was explained like i
had no choice like this is the only way
i could stop these people right he took
over the a bad person he says
he took over the mind of a killer a
murderer you know someone who didn't
like feel human he was a complete
sociopath
right
and yes he had to go against his own
ideology to complete his end call
in the end but he suffers from it
because he still remembers he sees all
the memories in the past
and that's how he pays for it right and
it's like wow like it was funny for a
second and then that's like so deep and
complex about
a character
like uh
what do you call it like a convolution
that they're going through this yeah
this
dichotomy that they have to live with
that's something that i also appreciated
too is that a lot of the characters were
developed just enough yeah everyone had
a reason even the even the nerd tech guy
yeah they gave him a little little
something too he wasn't just the nerd
tech guy die beard right yeah he was
the reason why he is the way he is and
the reason why peacemaker was actually
[ __ ]
ripping into him yeah you know about
stuff that was his insecurities was even
revealed in there too yeah so that's why
when he has like these victorious
moments it's him proving to himself that
he's not a [ __ ] loser yeah you know
like the chainsaw scene
this show gets wild
that's another thing like like we're not
even talking about like the other things
that make the show great we're going
like deep into that character study
outside of that you know like how we
talked about like um the matrix like we
don't give a [ __ ] about the fight scenes
or whatever like even in the batman the
newest one more like fight scenes
alright but we mainly talk about what's
happening in the story
the the wild fight scenes and the [ __ ]
that happens in this movie in between
all the great dialogue and character
study is still like top-notch yeah you
know so like the the butterflies like
it's kind of implement like kind of
hinted like foreshadowing that um
gorilla has gone missing yeah it turns
out that the butterflies took over a
[ __ ] gorilla body yeah and they have
to fight a [ __ ] gorilla that's just
so [ __ ] funny dude yeah the chaos the
chaotic moment somehow just like hits me
too yeah [ __ ] hilarious you get to
see to the extent of how much of a piece
of [ __ ] his dad is is when um
not even so much a piece of [ __ ] but his
power in terms of he how he represents
like the forgotten white people when he
goes to jail yeah
like he's he starts getting worshipped
he gets worshipped in there he is the
representation of white oppression yeah
yeah
so these people in prison when as soon
as it comes in like they they get down
on their knees and they do the the
[ __ ] salute and [ __ ] right and then
they say hail dragon or some [ __ ] like
that right
and then that's the foreboding thing
we're like oh [ __ ] this guy is somebody
he's not just his piece of [ __ ] that
like ray's dad like
yeah he's like
ooh like this foreboding evil coming
and i think he paints it so [ __ ] well
i think the one thing that reminded like
peacemaker too that um
makes him a really complex character
that kind of reminded me of you was no
matter how shitty his dad was he was
still like pining for his dad's
affection yes oh god that that that was
my
my unicorn yeah thinking that i can get
this
ideological perfect fatherly love from
him if i love him back
and that was like this dream i would
constantly chase that just wasn't gonna
come yeah yeah yeah
and that's the thing too that i didn't
like about shang chi yeah like because
one move was such a great dance yeah
like but in other people's eyes when
they see this film right the only thing
that they're thinking about is that is
that one
just beaten dead horse of a topic of you
know oh asian dad expects perfection
from kid
that doesn't mean that he doesn't love
his child yeah
that doesn't mean that at all like your
parents also too expected a certain
amount of what what is called
quote-unquote um perfection out of you
but do you not love your dad do you look
at your parents like they're a piece of
[ __ ] yeah because
you'll see this part two and
i really liked how you brought it back
to shanghi because of this one part
he kills his father yeah
yeah
he
balls yeah his [ __ ] eyes out laments
yeah right and by the way his dad came
to kill him
[Music]
you know he his dad even
put him to that point call him a [ __ ]
you won't do it you won't [ __ ] kill
me and he kills him kills him [ __ ]
luger all his eyes out yeah shanxi watch
his dad get absorbed he goes okay yeah
he just goes away
what the [ __ ] your dad just died and
then he just like like see you on this
magic dragon and how is he a good person
he's not he's supposed to be the hero of
that film yeah would you see this guy
who was
constantly pining for his father's
affection despite the fact that he's a
piece of [ __ ] which honestly too is way
more realistic yeah because no because
you see that all the time i see it with
friends of mine who have had such
terrible parents growing up and they had
to go through extensive therapy to
figure this out it's like why the [ __ ]
is that it's because he's still my dad
yes and i still want my dad's love and
affection yeah that is the human
experience right that makes more sense
and that's the the conundrum with the
lost
generation of white americans
that it's that it's showing that these
men these white men like what the rest
of the world sees them as shitty
especially on twitter
you know but who do they go to for
advice
they're shitty you're [ __ ] fathers
but these people are trying to be good
people
how many times do you see these second
amendment dudes saying we're the good
guys yeah we're the good guys that's
[ __ ] peacemaker yeah
you're not saying this show opens up
people like adebayo to look at white
americans like him and be like give him
a [ __ ] chance yeah you know
i think that's what's so amazing
and that's what's so therapeutic to me
when i see this show because of all the
[ __ ] i had going on at my store like i
said peacemaker is a customer at my
store um it really touched in a place
where like it shows a way it shows a
path it shows redemption
you know yeah through a tumultuous
relationship that they have through the
plot yeah yeah and even at that point
too where he feels absolutely betrayed
by her yeah they still find their way
back to becoming friends yeah and
trusting each other and trusting each
other too yeah like she was tight though
when she [ __ ] started running and
started [ __ ] people up yeah like
finally she gets to look a little cool
but she puts on the [ __ ]
helmet
dude i was like
that visually alone was so funny
the funny thing too is like the moment
she put it on i'm like this is a bad
idea because he already warned her yeah
like this one is this one's a dumb
helmet you know
but it just it was so good though
oh that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] funny too oh
man there's another scene that cracked
me the [ __ ] up is because throughout the
whole film they made me seem like
eagerly
and
peacemaker could talk to each other
and then bring it all the way over to
the bar to the barn which is where this
thing is it's this mother butterfly that
basically is their source for their food
and energy yeah and once that's
destroyed they'll kill them and you know
basically the cow the cow the cow yeah
and they
kind of the whole film oh the whole
series makes you feel like eagle is
hyper intelligent yeah and understands
everything peacemaker says yeah he's
like some kind of scooby-doo [ __ ] or
something no but this one takes the
helmet it just drops off in the middle
of a forest
i mean because they built it up because
like eagley hugs peacemaker right and
it's so so the first time his dad sees
it and he thinks it's like gay or
something he walks away
and then the other time it's like oh my
god it's a miracle it inspires
you to to continue the mission with the
team like a sign from god yeah
equally close and just does some
[ __ ] eagle [ __ ]
it's like it totally dies in the water
dude that was a genius line too because
it was autobio and um the other agent
the blonde one
i think hardcore parkour hardcore right
so she's just like yeah man i saw that
uh the symbol when i you know eagerly
hugged him as a symbol that she
continues she goes why don't you think
it was a symbol for you to just go the
other way
she's like [ __ ] yeah
dude i mean that's why i love this show
it's just like because yeah it's like
what why why would you think it's so
hilarious how it questions itself yeah
but but like because but it doesn't so
intelligently
so at the end there's like this point
where he has to now make a choice
so he gets to see
what this whole reason is about which
what i explained was what the butterfly
mission is right right and this is where
this is the whole ending chapter of his
growth as a human being yeah you know
because before he was kind of see
everything in black and white
there wasn't really a moral dilemma when
he would make his choices right
especially with the way that he would
talk to people everything was just a
matter of fact yeah he's just like stuff
sweet cheeks
you know she has sweet cheese that's
what it is can't you see him chill yeah
now he has his thing as a character
where he actually thinks about his
choices yeah right and he actually
decides to kill the mother cow yeah
in the most disgusting way the most
disgusting way that's just james go i
mean did you see the suicide squad yes
okay you're right and i mean and they
had a big kaiju at the end too right
what
i was so grossed out by that [ __ ] you
know me and like marine life you know
like that [ __ ] gross me the [ __ ] and
he's really good at grossing people out
but this cow didn't gross me up that bad
my roommate was [ __ ] dying like he
couldn't handle looking at that cow it
was so gross and disgusting to him but
yeah i mean
so
he activates
human torpedo
and bisons right into the cow and like
falls right through him and all the guts
of the cow come it's so disgusting and
that kills the butterflies food source
and life sorts so from there they'll
only live for the next hundred years now
for whatever they have left yeah right
and then um
when
they they get to the hospital to get
hardcore into
uh yeah into the er but
before they do they're walking out and
the [ __ ] justice league appears did
you see that coming oh yeah i didn't see
that coming at all even that [ __ ] was
hilarious hilarious one simple line you
guys are [ __ ] late
yeah go why don't you go [ __ ] a fish
and then like and then the light like
first they're just a silhouette and then
the light comes on and it's [ __ ]
jason mama it's actually him yeah it's
actually him and he's like i hate that
rumor
so it it completes the full sucker of
this constant rumors that that [ __ ]
piece maker keeps making about like all
these superheroes
and then that the camera pans and it's
[ __ ] ezra miller the actual flash too
i mean like you can see they couldn't
get gagudo or like henry cavill or some
[ __ ] but still
like they [ __ ] got them and now it's
canon yeah
like it's canon like
aquaman [ __ ] fish rumor right it's so
dope dude just everything wraps up so
[ __ ] nicely man yeah it was
interesting you know one thing i didn't
understand was
so there's uh what was the button the
butterfly called the leader
the one that was in the jar goth
so goff is at the end you see goff with
peacemaker he's maker right yeah and he
still has some of the goop left from the
mother and he just gives it and they're
kind of just chilling with each other
well i guess like at that point goth
doesn't have a mission because he's
going to die so now it's like yeah all
right this is who we are like he's the
last of his species he's the last of his
kind yeah and
as he accepts it he's he's just going to
because
even before the the whole scene and at
the end in the base the cow base like
um like she tells
uh peacemaker the entire plan that these
butterflies have which you mentioned was
like to save the planet you know from
climate change or whatever all these
social economic things this and that
that if they just take over the world
leaders then they'll make this world
peace
right and and this was the
conversation that um arabiyo and uh
peacemaker had in the waiting room as
hardcords in the er or in surgery or
whatever
like
she asked him why
she didn't
just you know join the butterflies i
thought that was your
you know um whole mission
was that you'll do anything for peace
you know and you didn't
you didn't do it and she actually judges
like like assumes that he made that
decision
because he's this ultra like like right
wing libertarian yeah yeah yeah because
nobody can tell me what to do yeah kind
of american right but no he says no
because that means i'd lose all my
friends
all my friends would be butterflies yeah
right
and a lot of what you see that's left
in peacemaker
out of all the [ __ ] that he can't hold
dear is loyalty
because he tries to get loyalty from his
father and you know and his father came
to [ __ ] kill him yeah
and yet it's this black ops team
like even harcourt and arabia have that
have the argument about what loyalty and
what team
you know and what it means to be a
soldier in this means
right and and then that last remaining
bit of what's important
to peacemaker you know is friendship
yeah his relationship is that autobio
and all these people who [ __ ] hate
him are his friends
he got over the hump that his friends
are like inanimate like
a [ __ ] alien butterfly
an eagle yeah and this a hyper autistic
kid who he's not he doesn't consider him
his best friend yeah he doesn't consider
him he just considers that peacemaker's
best friend but how his character has
grown to accept all these different
walks of life of different types of
american people that we see
become his best friends yeah and like
even with his relationship with hardcore
he's not just trying to [ __ ] her anymore
like he's having a genuine relationship
with her
it's like
james gunn
that's that's just [ __ ] a plus
peacemaker is
one of the most like
i would say the most complete superhero
series
ever yeah
it has everything that i want in terms
of story acting character development
even the cinematic i was telling um uh
at this too it's like the way that a
shot has like even an indie vibe to it
yeah it's very artistic for something so
goofy yeah it's
a whole lot of natural light yes which a
lot of people like filming in like uh
seattle and vancouver bc is the canadian
hollywood
um because the cloudy skies 200 days of
the year yup just makes an even
everybody's so good
yeah but it just it just looked a lot of
like handheld shots not a lot of things
on sticks it just had like a really good
raw feel to it yeah which i was kind of
shocked i didn't think that the
cinematography of a superhero film would
be like that yeah um
so it was just a really pleasant
surprise it just had everything that i
really enjoyed yeah i like looking at
series 2 where it ends
where it feels complete where i actually
don't want more because i think like
this is good yeah don't don't [ __ ] with
this anymore and i'll just go back and
watch it again um like maybe they'll do
like a follow-up of this but i wonder if
they definitely have announced a season
two okay sure yeah it's it's just so
[ __ ] i wonder how they're gonna top this
first season
yeah yeah i have no idea yeah because
okay so at the end we see
that the ghost of his father starts
following him around
but the ghost of his father is kind of
helping him yeah and that was an
interesting
like character turn like or where the
where his story goes right so the ghost
of his father starts haunting him you
know because peacemaker murdered are not
murdered like killed his father
as if there's a difference get murdered
um
and
i feel like the next
season would be very interesting
character study deeper into
how he struggles to live with
because let's yeah like like my father
passed away too right and i'm only left
with the memories of who he is and how
he applies into my life now
you know yeah you know a lot of things
that i cut out and a lot of things that
still make me who i am today
so i'm very interested in how the second
season comes about with the ghost of his
racist evil father yeah following him
around that'd be very [ __ ]
interesting so it can be anything
because i didn't know [ __ ] about who
peacemaker is in the comics or any of
that [ __ ] i mean you can find it online
but
where he's taking it anyway like i'm
there yeah i'm on board
yeah for sure well guys that wraps up
this episode of the genius brain podcast
where we covered peacemaker
for a long time coming a lot of people
have been asking for this but [ __ ] was
this really really really really good if
you don't know anything about comic
books or you don't give a [ __ ] about
comic books just watch peacemakers yeah
it doesn't even matter it doesn't matter
it's just that [ __ ] good it almost
looks like a
uh it almost seems like a series that
just makes fun of superheroes yeah it's
like the
it's like it's it's it's like the
deadpool for dc but it's not so meta but
it's also like watchmen where it looks
at to what superheroes would be like in
the real world actually like these crazy
people
yeah well guys you can catch ed at ed
parkvp and geniusbrains every sundays at
12pm and we'll see you all next time
peace